welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and this is a breakdown of peacemaker
episode 5 monkey dory which is quite the
fitting title because good lord did
things get ape [ __ ] crazy in this
episode of charlie and the chainsaw
factory so let's quit monkeying around
and get it on like donkey kong because
all these sweet dc details and
references that you missed are not going
to break down themselves until you know
robots take over the world and then
maybe they'll be an adler of them we
start off the episode with peacemakers
super disgusting breakfast drink of eggs
hot sauces and salt and pepper which of
course served to foreshadow peacemaker's
terrible bartending skills during him
and leota's nightcap at the end of the
episode but is also sort of reflective
of peacemaker's militaristic approach to
how he ingests calories with basically
only consuming the bare essentials for
optimum peacemaking like the fact that
chris doesn't even cook the egg yet
allows the butterfly to have his
favorite breakfast both shows how he
kind of thinks that broken things
deserve second chances but also that he
doesn't consider himself worthy of that
second chance and when leota's boo thing
drops by to check in on her in to make
sure that no infidelities were going on
leota is wearing this amazing work shirt
that i think was purposely designed to
look like black blood splatters to
visually symbolize how leota is
basically slowly acquiring more
metaphorical blood on her hands just
like her mom amanda waller one of the
worst people to ever live and when leota
texts with her mom there are actually no
previous texts in her history meaning
that they're probably set to
automatically erase a way of showing the
heartless secrecy that she learned from
amanda waller and by contrast the group
later shows their family bonding by
starting a group text chain something
that leota never had with her mom amanda
waller and when the team is getting a
butterfly briefing from the disgusting
straw mouth of a butterfly in disguise
that is mirn we learned that billionaire
ceo of waresoft alan kupperberg was a
butterfly which is a reference to dc
comics illustrator alan kuperberg known
for his work on comics like firestorm
the warlord and justice league of
america and is also the brother of dc
comics writer paul kupperberg who was a
creator of the dc comics checkmate a
small task force x offshoot team loosely
monitored by task force x to go on
missions to protect america's interests
and appears to be the very team the dceu
is setting up with peacemakers off the
book team set up and loosely monitored
by task force x's amanda waller so
basically peacemaker's team is checkmate
but anyways during john economos his
master for use of microsoft powerpoint
we do get the very important piece of
information that butterflies can crawl
up your butt which seems just like a
silly joke made on a presentation but
could actually be a hint towards how all
of these butterflies have been able to
spread around the world so damn quickly
probably just by traveling up through
people's buttholes through the sewage
systems of society invasion of the
butthole snatchers in a little fun
animation detail that i loved economos
designed the 3d model to demonstrate the
butterfly's booty entry to look super
muscular you know the exact freaky build
of one christopher smith a hilarious dig
by economist you know sort of get back
at chris for calling him die beard all
those times and when vigilante mentioned
that he thought that the man and the
chimp in the presentation were friends
this could be a reference to dc comics
detective chimp a sentient chimp who
works with humans to solve crimes you
know mostly mystical ones but prime's
all the same any sort of crimes and
peacemaker also claims that superman has
a poop fetish enlists a long list of
names of celebrities that they could
have framed instead of his dad and even
throwing in a lighthearted dig at
riverdale the cw series by greg berlanti
who oversees the other dc superhero tv
universe and in the post-credits scene
he mentions danny glover and mel gibson
stars of lethal weapon a movie which
played on mern's tv last episode and in
case you haven't seen him already during
the always amazing peacemaker intros
judo master can actually be seen hiding
in the background while people are
dancing in a couple of shots because if
there's anything i know about james gunn
is that the man knows how to hide an
easter egg in plain sight
i see you james i see you and speaking
of sewage the sign outside of the gang's
vehicle got switched out from the
x-static electric company sign to lay
the pipe plumbing so you know in case
you didn't think economos was in charge
of the visual graphics before
now you know because that's definitely
something that economists would do and
then of course vigilante who after last
week's beautiful rant against racism is
invited to the cookout whips out a
chainsaw coincidentally a weapon of
choice of another one of james gunn's
other written creations lollipop
chainsaw and good god is that game
really weird really fun but really weird
and hey if you've been enjoying
peacemaker on hbo max as much as we have
and would like to celebrate it with some
flair our merch partners at epic hero
shop have some awesome t-shirt options
for you and your mom and your dad and
maybe a dog some one of these days there
are two really cool peacemaker inspired
shirts in the shop right now the full
metal peacemakers shirt is a riff on the
classic fullmetal jacket movie poster
but with peacemaker's iconic helmet with
eatpiece mf scribbled on it i'll leave
it up to your imagination to as to what
mf means it means
the other shirt crest of peace has
peacemaker writing a jumble version of
eagerly and would totally be appropriate
to wear while doing a synchronized dance
to hair metal with all of your friends
an epic hero has all kinds of cool merch
inspired by all of your favorite
properties like loki book of boba fett
and spider-man no way home and there's
even a dove of peace sticker that you
can slap on your nerf gun so that when
you blast your nephew with their
surprise attack you will be doing it in
the name of peace so sign up for their
newsletter at the bottom of their
website to get notified about the latest
merch drops and check out all of their
incredible products at the
epichiroshop.com
and be your own hero today we finally
get to see that x-ray vision helmet that
chris stole from his dad in action as he
uses it to identify and shoot
butterflies in the [ __ ] face
which kind of reminds me of a scene from
james gunn's other adult superhero
project super when rain wilson uses a
shotgun to storm a compound of bad guys
and as the team snoops around the
factory some of the tanks that the
butterflies have are labeled fermenting
tank leaving it a mystery as to what all
this weird yellow goop stuff even is but
judging how the butterflies tend to
prefer to live in human brains i'm
guessing that this fluid could be a
liquefied version of human brains
themselves left to ferment until the
right time their chemical composition
becomes friendly to the butterflies
because butterflies need their nectar
after all and i don't think that
butterflies can eat the food that we can
eat with our digestive system and of
course we gotta give it up to horror
movie aficionado james gunn for the
incredible reference to invasion of the
body snatchers with that creepy point
and screech
[Applause]
with of course invasion of the body
snatchers being one of james gunn's top
four favorite horror films from the 70s
alongside jaws the brood and martin
george a romero's martin not martin
lawrence's martin damn and when
detective song visits amber and evan we
see that amber is a dungeon mistress
meaning that she's a dm in her dungeons
and dragons groups and of course like
early peacemaker episodes and economos's
chimp inclusion in the powerpoint
foreshadowed we finally find out where
charlie the gorilla went off to and get
visual confirmation that butterflies can
indeed infect animals which kind of
makes me wonder if peacemaker's bug
friend and eagerly will end up bonding
in more ways than 420 if you know what i
mean but then charlie is suddenly and
gruesomely chainsawed from behind by the
econo goat himself which despite being
an event that strangely causes the team
to bond closer kind of makes me worried
that vigilante is going to feel
threatened by economos mostly because
chris started calling economos icona
goat and vigilante thimble you know like
chris used to do when he used to bully
adrian's monopoly piece penis in the
past and after the playing of 11th
street kids hanoi rocks was cut off
before
we're here the victorious return trip
allows the team to fully rock out to it
like kids all coming home from school
after making a b honor roll and stopping
for ice cream and finally we gotta close
out this breakdown with the greatest and
most exciting reveal in this entire
episode fan favorite batman villain kite
man has been confirmed to be dceu cannon
baby like this is literally the greatest
day of my life i've wanted a dceu kite
man forever so all i need to do now is
just see him because apparently he was
sort of peacemaker's joker with this
newspaper clip and basically saying that
kite man was the first person that
peacemaker took down like all i really
need now is for auggie's nosy neighbor
to be confirmed as the mad hatter and my
life will be officially complete i'll be
able to die happy but that is it for our
breakdown of episode 5 of peacemaker
monkey dory what did you guys think of
the episode let us know in the comment
section below my beautiful nerd babies
but again thank you guys so much for
watching this video follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] and some really
interesting theories but more
importantly follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media
especially on youtube where you can hit
that notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a new
video and also please be sure to hit up
new rockstarsmerch.com so you can get
awesome amazing nerd shirts and also
join us on discord so you can join our
nerd conversations there just make sure
you are 18 years old and older but
anyways i love you guys so so much thank
you guys for spending time with me i'll
see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you